Now part of this video is to obviously
test out gnarly eye juice,
but the other part is
to prove that safety
goggles work or something.
I guess, wear safety goggles.
So I'm gonna use this BB gun,
there you go.
Bear in mind,
these safety goggles are about
30 years old, so.
30 years old?
Yeah; I reckon it's just gonna
go straight through you know?
It won't.
It will.
Why would it go straight through?
These are old glasses.
No they're guaranteed for up to 31 years.
Ready?
yep.
Oh it didn't come out.
Yeah it did.
Did it?
It went in.
I told you.
It went straight through.
Shame I missed the odds.
It's gone straight through.
That is awful.
You ready to get, eye gunk on you?
Fine.
Okay ready?
yeah.
Oh.
Did eye gunk come out?
I didn't see any come out.
It just seems to go straight through.
Did it?
Nothing happened.
Well crap.
Yeah.
What do you think of that video then?
I'm just really sad it didn't work out
to be honest.
You're sad?
Yeah.
Oh.
Oh my god.
There's the water though.
I'm gonna get the hose out.
Dude I'm not being funny?
Some of that absolutely twatted my head.
Flippin' twatted me, yeah.
Geez, look at that there,
it twatted me on the side of the head.
Killed.
Absolutely killed.
Let's have a look at your head.
Pure melon did that.
Melon, yeah.
yeah.
How does it feel?
Fine now, but it hurt at the time.
You wanna hear something disgusting?
After that shot, I went to clean the water
out of the lens, and I was
wiping it with a cloth,
and it was all oily
and I was just smearing
this weird oil on the lens
and I couldn't get it clean.
Looking back at the footage,
realized the eye flew
out the melon, hit the
camera directly in the lens.
I was just smearing eye
juice over the lens.
I didn't even know it.
That is just disgusting.
If you wanna see the full
version of the pig's eye video,
you can click that link here right now.
It's got all the high
speed of the bullet hitting
the eye and the goop and
slime, it's pretty gross.
But if you're into
that, give that a click.
This video is brought
to you by Audible.com
and if you wanna sign up using the link
Audible.com/slowmo you
can get a free audio book.
There's over 150 thousand
books to choose from.
I'm gonna recommend "A
Clash of Kings" this time,
because I finished "Game of Thrones"
and I've moved on.
Next book please.
Also, after you've done that,
you should subscribe to
the slowmo guys channel
and after that, you should
probably do something
more productive because I imagine you've
been on into that for quite some time now.